are you ready for one of my spicy hot
takes
well i guess the title kind of gives it
away in advance doesn't it
so what led me to this conclusion why do
i think that libertarians
right libertarians to be specific are
fascists
and of course i'm not talking about
every single person who identifies as
libertarian
or even right libertarian but i did
notice some worrying trends among people
who call themselves that
and also libertarianism has become an
integral part of the republican party
which is a far-right party by any
measure so there appears to be some
definite connection between
the far right and right libertarianism
but why
i mean theoretically they're supposed to
be on different ends of the spectrum
you know right-wing authoritarians
wanting more government control
at least in theory and the right
libertarians wanting less
and so here we arrive at an absolutely
crucial distinction
when i say right-wing libertarian i
don't mean
people who fit the definition of
right-wing libertarian i mean
people who identify as right-wing
libertarian
and so do the following names sound
familiar to you
richard spencer milo yiannopoulos gavin
mcinnis
tim giannay aka baked alaska
ben shapiro all of these people are far
right demagogues
all of them have either started out or
are currently identifying as
libertarian and so it seems to me that
there is such a thing as the libertarian
alt-right pipeline
and why is that well if you're a
libertarian
allegedly chances are you will be
against programs such as
affirmative action state welfare
anti-discrimination legislation
now do we see a pattern here in general
it seems to me that far writers and
libertarians have an awful lot in common
and that's because they both believe in
this thing called personal
responsibility
so when you tell young people that
the cause of the trouble they see around
them in the world and maybe even the
disquiet in their own heart is the
malevolent inadequacy
of their society that rings true
and they don't hear the rest of the
story you know and it's the rest of the
story that i've been trying to tell they
don't
hear the story that yeah don't forget
about the evil and corruption that
exists in your own heart
if you're a member of the left and you
believe that all individuals are
essentially just
the outgrowths of institutions and
therefore that all
change by individuals is going to be
insufficient and that it must be
societal change that
that creates individual change you're a
threat because you're telling people
well you know the systems can certainly
get better but the
main threat to you is you and that is a
deeply threatening message to people and
if people find fulfillment in that
message
then the left really does have a problem
because if people start improving their
lives within the system
and not blaming the system for their
problems and instead
recognizing that that they can improve
their lives that's what
members left hate most of all you know
you talk about in the book jordan the
fact that people are constantly coming
up to you and they're saying things like
you know i i was leading a dissolute
life
i read your book i started taking your
advice and i've turned it around and now
i'm doing much better in life
and you know i'm blessed to have much
the same experience from a lot of people
who listen to the show people who have
been homeless who now have graduated
harvard law school
people who were single moms and and then
and then decided to to take a college
course and and figure out their lives
people who've made mistakes and turn
their mistakes around
and to me those are inspirational
stories i think that because those
inspirational stories exist that i think
is why people find you to be such a
threat it's because so many people are
inspired by the stuff that you say
and change their life individually
without putting all of their iron focus
on a system that the left is mainly
focused on tearing down
so there you have it individual
responsibility means that we should
solve
big problems through small individual
changes instead of systemic approaches
the system isn't broken the individual
people are
you know if you have 10 000 black people
living in a ghetto somewhere
the systemic solution to black poverty
would be targeted social programs
improving the infrastructure enforcing
laws against discrimination
and so on and so forth whereas what ben
personal responsibility shapiro would do
is he would roll up in his bentley and
tell those people to start a business or
something
which is basically just the equivalent
of hand waving the issues of those
people like yeah whatever just
start a business or something and that's
because if you subscribe to the idea of
personal responsibility
then chances are you believe that the
system we have currently is
fine or mostly fine and so the problems
don't lie in the institutions
they lie in the individual people hey
would you look at that
sounds like these right-wing
libertarians really want to conserve
the current system wow i wonder if
there's a political movement dedicated
to that exact goal
so yeah basically if we follow the idea
of personal responsibility
we end up invariably with conservative
social policies
quite the coincidence isn't it so if the
um
dorkies get duopoly in detroit that
they're poor and they have no
opportunities
well it's their problem they're just
lazy they don't want to work and if some
soy chugging cocked lefty points out
that
hey by the way there's been systemic
discrimination against black people
redlining policies ramming highways
through neighborhoods
you know the disproportionate
incarceration of black people for
non-violent drug crimes breaks up
families and ruins communities
all of these concerns can be just
hand-waved dismissed with personal
responsibility
because you can just tell them well
liberal you say
let's say that black people are let's
say discriminated against but
have you heard about this thing called
personal responsibility hmm yep they can
just they can just move or they can just
create a business
they can just uh let's say stop being
poor if they want to but they don't what
does this mean about them
right so basically all social issues are
channeled back onto the individual
if you see a bunch of black folk in a
ghetto your first question will not be
what system produced this inequality but
rather how come all these people are so
lazy
and oh boy does this result in some
interesting follow-up questions
you know how come all these black people
seem to be unable to succeed in this
meritocratic fair society created by
white people
is it a cultural problem or more of a
biological problem hey would you look at
that
from one of the biggest foundational
principles of libertarianism
we have organically arrived at white
nationalist talking points
and this we call the libertarian
alt-right pipeline
and the main issue of this libertarian
idea of personal responsibility
is that it's just so [ __ ] vague what
does personal responsibility mean
in what sense in what context in what
philosophical framework
and the answer is whatever you feel like
i mean it's so vague it can be anything
that's the beauty of it and this exact
same thing happens to the other
fundamental libertarian ideas which are
complete control over your person
and your property and so christopher
cantwell a speaker at the unite the
right rally at charlottesville
also known as the crying nazi a former
libertarian by the way
wrote the following in his blog
following charlottesville people should
be free to exercise complete control
over their own person
and property if blacks are committing
crimes or jews are spreading communism
discriminating against them is the right
of any property owner
the fact that he may or may not miss out
on good blacks or jews is a risk he
takes
and the merit of his decisions will be
proven out by the market
so once again the ideas he takes as a
basis are so vague that he can just
effortlessly integrate his beliefs into
them and it all works out okay
and so if you are a person with empathy
and a good understanding of the world
you realize that currently in certain
areas of life especially in america
systemic change is needed to bring about
more happiness and better outcomes
and that requires state social policies
anti-discrimination laws
affirmative action even welfare programs
which will also go to a lot of non-white
people due to their socio-economic
circumstances
in today's america white people seem to
have most of the power
and if you tolerate the status quo or
who knows maybe even support it
then it is quite simply in your best
interest to side with political forces
that are all about maintaining the
current status quo
and would you look at that
libertarianism does exactly that
so this is libertarianism from a social
perspective acting is an ideological
platform for all kinds of unsavory folks
on the far right
but hey you might interject
libertarianism is not just that
it also has a lot to say about economics
it wants to free the markets it wants
more freedom for everyone freedom to do
business freedom to
buy or sell whatever they want it's all
about achieving liberty free of any
government meddling
hence the name libertarianism it all
sounds nice
but here's the problem hierarchy is
inherent
in capitalism your boss can be an
incompetent [ __ ] who just got
parachuted into his position through his
relatives or something
and still have all the power over you
while you have no power over them
and they can decide about your
livelihood with a stroke of a pen
capitalism is also coercive what if your
boss is a total emotionally abusive
[ __ ] who just makes employees life a
living hell
i've had those bosses before it's not
fun and i ended up resigning in all
situations
but only because i had plenty of options
but what if i didn't
i'd be screwed i would have had to show
up to work take all the abuse with a
smile on my face and then pray to god i
don't get fired
because if i do i'm sleeping under the
bridge right
so it seems to me that right-wing
libertarianism is not really concerned
with
you know liberty and it's only used as a
facade for the true agenda
which is the creation and maintaining of
hierarchies
and that we call right-wing conservatism
which happens to be a precursor to
right-wing fascism
and a few years ago this would have been
a rather outlandish statement
however since then we had the republican
party's hardship towards the far right
four years of donald trump we had
charlottesville and the
very fine people on both sides and then
we had the attack on the capitol which
was essentially a coup attempt by trump
supporters
and came about as a result of donald
trump questioning the result of a
legitimate democratic election
with most of the republican parties
backing by the way so that's why i'm so
comfortable calling right-wing fascism
a natural and logical continuation of
ripened conservatism
because as conservatism transitions
towards the far right it becomes less
and less distinguishable from right-wing
fascism
the symptoms which i believe are there
for anyone to see
and that is why right-wing libertarians
always turn out to be
fascists oh and by the way i do believe
in the importance of personal
responsibility
i think we should all be responsible for
our actions i think no one on the left
is seriously saying that we shouldn't
only that next to the very important
personal responsibility
we should have systemic solutions for
systemic problems
that's my view as well and i think it's
completely fair
anyway that was my hot take about
right-wing libertarianism i hope you
enjoyed it and hey if you want to see
more of my content hit the like button
and subscribe
and i'll see you at some point